Karl Benz - Father of the Automobile
Looking back on humanity’s achievements,
you can pinpoint certain landmark moments
that changed the world forever.
One such moment was, undoubtedly, the birth
of the automobile which, like rail transport
before it and aviation afterwards, completely
revolutionized how humans moved around.
Many people deserve credit for this achievement.
As you are about to find out, the concept
of the “first car in the world” is, by
no means, a settled matter, but the lion’s
share of the accolades goes to Karl Benz who
designed and built what is regarded by many
as the true first automobile.
They say that behind every great man, there
is a great woman and, perhaps, there is no
better example than Bertha Benz.
She was there to support her husband through
thick and thin, enjoying the highs together
and using her own money to get him back on
his feet during the lows.
Then, of course, there was also her iconic
road trip which solidified the car as a practical
machine.
Bertha’s daringness combined with Karl’s
engineering genius ensured that people finally
looked at the car as something that could
actually be used in day-to-day life.
We’ve come a long way since then, but it
would be completely fair to say that the automotive
industry would not be what it is today without
Karl Benz.
Early Years
Karl Benz, sometimes spelled with a C instead
of a K, was born Karl Friedrich Vaillant on
November 25, 1844, in the German town of Mühlburg
which today is a borough of Karlsruhe in the
state of Baden-Württemberg.
His name was Vaillant because his father,
Johann Georg Benz, and his mother, Josephine
Vaillant, were not married at the time of
his birth.
However, they did, in fact, marry a few months
later and the baby became Karl Friedrich Benz.
Johann Benz was a locomotive driver, but he
died in an accident when Karl was only two
years old.
This left the family in dire financial straits,
but the mother did her best to ensure a good
education for her son.
Young Karl followed in his father’s footsteps
and studied engineering and, from an early
age, proved to be a prodigious student.
In fact, when he was just 19 years old, Karl
Benz graduated with a degree in mechanical
engineering from the University of Karlsruhe.
This was in 1864 and yet, it would be a while
before Benz finally found his vocation in
life.
He spent the next seven years trying out various
jobs with multiple construction and engineering
firms throughout Germany, but he found them
all to be unsatisfying.
At the same time, he became an avid bicycle
rider and enjoyed tinkering with them, fantasizing
about a similar vehicle that would be motorized.
In 1871, Karl Benz started his first business.
He partnered with a mechanic named August
Ritter and opened the Iron Foundry and Mechanical
Workshop in Mannheim.
The company was not successful and, within
a year, it was struggling financially.
Fortunately for Benz, he soon found a better
partner, one who would have an enormous impact
on his life and the development of the automobile
- his bride-to-be, Bertha Ringer.
Karl and Bertha
Bertha Ringer had been born in a time when
it was firmly believed that women had no business
with scientific and mechanical matters and
that even just exerting their brains would
decrease their ability to have children.
Certainly not the case here - Karl and Bertha
would go on to have five children together.
And yet, even when she was young, Bertha took
an interest in engineering.
According to a particularly heartbreaking
legend, she became determined to show the
world that women were capable of achieving
great things after reading her family’s
Bible one day and finding an entry that said
“Unfortunately only a girl again” - written
by her father, on the day she was born.
Whether this story is true or not, the elder
Mr. Ringer did leave Bertha a substantial
dowry after working as a successful carpenter
all his life.
Besides her wealth, Bertha Ringer was also
a beautiful and clearly intelligent woman.
When she reached marrying age, she had a long
list of potential suitors to choose from.
And yet, fate led to a poor, disheveled engineer
named Karl Benz to share the same coach as
Bertha and her mother during an excursion
in 1869.
The two started talking and, as soon as Karl
brought up a horseless carriage he was working
on, he captured Bertha’s interest and, soon
enough, her heart.
Despite warnings and admonishments from her
family, Bertha’s mind was made up - Karl
was the man she wanted to be with for the
rest of her life.
The couple married in 1872.
Bertha’s support of her husband was unwavering.
Her first act was to use part of her dowry
to buy out August Ritter’s share in Benz’s
company.
The rest of her money was used to keep the
business afloat while Karl worked on new patents.
Although Benz was, undoubtedly, a genius engineer
and designer, nobody could ever accuse him
of being a shrewd businessman.
The Benz Companies
Benz’s first great achievement was his stationary
gasoline two-stroke engine.
He was inspired by the work of an earlier
German engineer, Nikolaus Otto, who created
the first four-stroke engine in 1861.
Benz received a patent for his invention in
1880 and went on to add improvements such
as an engine speed regulation system and ignition
via a battery system.
This new device of Benz managed to garner
interest from banks and businessmen who wanted
to invest.
Because he needed the capital to grow his
company, Benz converted his business into
a joint-stock company named Gasmotoren-Fabrik
Mannheim in 1882.
This did not work out as he hoped it would.
After all the agreements were completed, Benz
ended up only owning five percent of the company.
More importantly, he did not have a say in
how the business was run, anymore.
Not a significant one, at least.
His partners had differing notions on what
products to design and sell and the engineer’s
ideas often went ignored.
Not happy with this arrangement, Karl Benz
left the corporation the following year.
Undeterred, Benz looked to start a new company
but, this time, he searched for more amenable
partners.
He found them in Max Rose and Friedrich Wilhelm
Esslinger, two men who owned a bicycle repair
shop in Mannheim.
Together, they established the Benz & Companie
Rheinische Gasmotoren-Fabrik, better known
simply as Benz & Co.
The business focused on manufacturing engines
and proved to be profitable, growing to 25
employees in a short amount of time.
This newfound success eased the pressure off
Benz a little bit and allowed him to indulge
in his passion project - building an automobile
using
his engine.
The First Car?
In 1885, Karl Benz finished his magnum opus
- the Benz Patent Motorwagen.
It was a two-seater vehicle.
It had three wire-spoke wheels and a single-cylinder,
gasoline-powered engine that formed a single
unit with the chassis and was capable of producing
0.75 horsepower and reaching top speeds of
10 mph.
Other bells and whistles on the vehicle included
a controlled exhaust valve, an automatic intake
slide, and high-voltage electrical vibrator
ignition with spark plug.
In January of 1886, Benz received patent number
37435 for his “vehicle powered by a gas
engine” or the “birth certificate of the
automobile”, as it came to be known.
Later in July, Benz drove his car in public
for the first time.
So was this the first car in the world?
Well, for the sake of simplicity, it is generally
regarded as the first automobile, but that
question is difficult to answer because it
depends on what your definition of an “automobile”
is.
The Motorwagen definitely does not look like
our idea of a “car” today, but it was
the first vehicle of its kind to be made commercially
available to the public.
Benz’s machine had another advantage over
designs that came before it in that it managed
to function without exploding or falling apart
while in operation.
The truth is that some people regard an automobile
as simply a self-propelled vehicle powered
by some kind of engine and, in that case,
we have to go even farther back than horseless
carriages.
French inventor Nicolas-Joseph Cugnot created
a full-size mechanical land vehicle called
the Fardier à vapeur back in 1769.
It weighed over 8,800 lbs and was powered
by steam.
In 1807, another Frenchman named Isaac de
Rivaz designed an experimental vehicle powered
by hydrogen gas.
Robert Anderson was a Scottish inventor who
created an electric carriage sometime during
the 1830s which was powered by non-rechargeable
batteries.
In 1867, Belgian Jean-Joseph-Etienne Lenoir
built a vehicle powered by an atmospheric
gas engine.
German Siegfried Marcus did something similar
a few years later by combining a handcart
with an atmospheric engine.
He did keep improving his design and ended
up with something that could be called a car,
but this happened in 1888, after the Benz
Patent Motorwagen.
We should also mention the French team of
Édouard Delamare-Deboutteville and his assistant
Leon Malandin who started work on a vehicle
with an internal combustion engine and a three-wheeled
chassis back in 1883.
Some people do argue that Delamare-Deboutteville
might deserve some of the accolades usually
given to Karl Benz, but the truth of the matter
is that his vehicle never functioned well
enough to go into production.
Last, but not least, we should also include
Gottlieb Daimler and Wilhelm Maybach who were
working on their own automobile independently
of Karl Benz, at the same time, about 60 miles
away.
They finished the Daimler Motorcoach a couple
of months after the Benz Motorwagen.
As you can see, the question of “Who built
the first car?” is a tricky one and does
not have a universal answer, although we can
generally agree that the Benz Patent Motorwagen
was the first practical automobile and, therefore,
set in motion the nascent stages of an industry
that would grow to become one of the biggest
in the world.
The Trip that Changed Everything
After the original Motorwagen came out, Benz
immediately went back to work.
Two new and improved models of his automobile
were released in the next couple of years.
But it seemed like the rest of the world did
not share Karl and Bertha’s vision for an
automotive future as demand for the Motorwagen
was not particularly high.
The Benz engine still sold nicely, but what
would be the point of buying a whole vehicle?
Up until then, these kinds of self-powered
machines were only used in trials over short
distances and still needed mechanics to be
on-hand.
There was no practicality to them whatsoever.
Not to mention the fact that they were expensive
and would have only been accessible to the
rich elite.
They were not interested, though, because
they considered something like the Motorwagen
to be too loud and messy - not very gentlemanly.
What the car needed was a bit of good PR.
Like we said before, Karl Benz was at his
best when he was getting his hands dirty in
the workshop.
Fortunately for him, Bertha had a better mind
for marketing and she realized that they needed
some kind of stunt not only to garner publicity
for their new product, but also to show people
that it had a purpose.
Therefore, in the early hours of a hot August
day in 1888, Bertha Benz jumped behind the
wheel of a Benz Patent Motorwagen No. 3 and
embarked on one of the most important automotive
journeys in history - the first long-distance
trip by car.
Bertha did not tell her husband of her plan.
She also did not inform the authorities so,
technically, what she did was illegal.
Bertha recruited her teenage sons, Richard
and Eugen, to tag along for the ride, and
left Mannheim in the morning on the pretense
of going to visit her mother in Pforzheim.
This was 66 miles away and, while that might
sound like a routine trip nowadays, it was
significantly longer than any journey that
had been previously attempted in any kind
of motorized carriage.
Moreover, Bertha had to contend with problems
that nobody else had to deal with, starting
with the fact that there were no roads suitable
for cars back then.
She had to follow wagon tracks for most of
the way and even went on ancient Roman roads
in some parts.
Another problem was fuel as the Motorwagen
needed to refuel every 15 to 20 miles and,
obviously, there were no gas stations anywhere.
Her automobile used a fuel called ligroin
which was a petroleum-based solvent that could
be bought at pharmacies.
Bertha made a stop at Wiesloch and paid a
visit to the local apothecary, looking to
buy ten liters of ligroin.
This startled the elderly chemist who saw
a young woman with stains on her dress and
naturally assumed that she wanted to use the
solvent to clean her clothes.
He offered her a one-liter bottle, noting
that that would be sufficient but Bertha,
of course, had no interest in clean clothes.
She was looking to refuel her car.
In the end, she purchased three liters of
ligroin which was all the chemist had in stock
but, since then, that pharmacy in Wiesloch
has branded itself the first fuel station
in the world.
It even has a monument of Bertha and her two
sons in front of it.
Other problems included needing to refill
the water tank regularly, a chain that broke
and had to be fixed by a blacksmith, the leather
brake pads that wore out and had to be replaced
by shoemakers, and even the occasional steep
hill where the boys had to get out and push
the car.
Bertha even showed off her own know-how on
occasion, using her garter to plug a leak
and hairpins to clear up clogged valves.
The 66-mile journey took over 12 hours, but
Bertha, Richard, and Eugen made it to Pforzheim
safely.
More importantly, the trip achieved its goal.
Many people took notice, some were even frightened
to the point of prayer by the crazy woman
speeding through their towns in a “smoking
monster.”
Almost overnight, everyone heard of the Benz
Patent Motorwagen.
And in case they missed her the first time,
they had another chance soon after because,
a few days later, Bertha and the boys returned
home in the same car, but on a different route.
Moreover, Bertha even identified a few ways
of improving the Benz car, such as adding
a new gear for climbing hills.
In 2008, this 121-mile long return-trip from
Mannheim to Pforzheim was declared a European
Route of Industrial Heritage and there is
a parade of antique cars that follows it every
two years in celebration of Bertha’s iconic
voyage.
Finding Success
Bertha’s trip was a turning point for the
automobile industry, but especially for the
Benz company.
Of course, we were still decades away from
the car becoming the standard method of transportation,
but people started to see it not as some kind
of oddity, but the way of the future.
The Benz Patent Motorwagen went on sale in
1888 and, bizarrely, it sold better in France
than in Germany.
Again, this was down to Karl Benz’s lack
of business acumen.
Because of this, transactions were slow in
his native country.
In France, however, the marketing was done
by a Parisian engineer and bicycle manufacturer
named Emile Roger who had more of a flair
for showmanship.
Roger was already a successful distributor
of Benz engines and he received sole agency
rights to sell Benz cars in France.
Some of his creative marketing ideas included
showing off his Motorwagen Model III at the
1889 World’s Fair and signing up the cars
for racing events.
There was some tension between the two because
Roger made an effort to minimize Benz’s
role in the development of the car and increase
his own.
He gave out leaflets to prospective buyers
that described the automobile, not once mentioning
the name “Benz.”
He made special Roger badges that he fitted
to the cars he sold and he made sure that
the vehicles he raced were all referred to
as Roger cars.
Even with Roger’s shenanigans, the Benz
company continued to grow and had to relocate
to a bigger production factory.
By 1890, it had become the second-largest
engine manufacturer in Germany and was poised
to grow even more after the addition of two
new partners - Friedrich von Fischer and Julius
Ganss.
As for Karl, he cared about the one thing
he always cared about - the engineering.
Throughout the 1890s, he came up and patented
several new innovations, most notably the
double-pivot steering, planetary gear transmission,
and the flat engine with a boxer configuration
which was better known as the contra engine
back then.
At the recommendation of his partners, Karl
designed a new and improved automobile - the
Benz Victoria which went on sale in 1892.
However, it was his follow-up design, the
Benz Velo, that really took off and came to
be regarded as the world’s first large-scale
production car.
By the end of its sales run in 1902, over
1,200 Velos had been sold.
And, while Karl was looking for new ways to
use his increasingly-powerful engines, he
also invented the motorized bus, originally
capable of seating eight people.
Although Benz & Co was successful, it was
feeling the heat from its number one competitor,
Daimler Motoren Gesellschaft (DMG) headed
by Gottlieb Daimler and Wilhelm Maybach.
Daimler passed away in 1900 but, just one
year later, Maybach designed and produced
his crowning achievement - the Mercedes 35
HP.
While previous cars still mostly looked like
coaches with engines fitted to them, this
was a vehicle we would consider to resemble
our modern idea of a car.
Not to mention that it was the first automobile
branded as a Mercedes.
And in case you were wondering where the Mercedes
name comes from, it was named after the daughter
of Austrian businessman Emil Jellinek who
not only commissioned the 35 HP, but was very
hands-on in its development and specifically
requested certain improvements that ensured
the car became a landmark moment in automotive
history.
To counter their competition, the Benz company
brought in some French designers to help with
new models.
This angered Karl Benz who resigned his position
in 1903, although he still remained on the
board of directors.
His sons Richard and Eugen soon followed suit
and they founded a new company, Carl Benz
Söhne, in 1906, headquartered in Ladenburg.
They searched for new markets and found success
in England where their cars became quite popular
as taxis.
Because the Benz family had enough capital
by this point, they never issued public stocks
in this new company so they could retain complete
control over it.
Benz Sons lasted until 1923, although Karl
Benz liquidated his shares and retired in
1912, leaving the business in the hands of
his sons.
During the 1920s, the German economy plummeted
and all industries were hurting, including
the automotive one.
In order to survive, Benz & Co and DMG signed
an “Agreement of Mutual Interest” in 1924.
The automakers combined their production and
marketing efforts while still retaining their
individual brands in order to save on costs.
This did not last long as just two years later,
they merged completely and formed Daimler-Benz.
Immediately, this deal was a success as their
sales tripled in 1927.
All their new vehicles were labeled as Mercedes-Benz,
a brand that is still as popular as ever.
Karl stayed on the board of directors for
the rest of his life.
He died on April 4, 1929, at the age of 84,
in his home in Ladenburg.
Bertha kept on living in the same home, until
she also passed away on May 5, 1944.
They both lived long enough to see the industry
that they helped create and dedicated their
entire lives to grow and thrive into one which
became indispensable
to humanity.